Musik Energie nicht. Ich habe die Energie nicht für dieses Intro, bin ich ganz ehrlich mit Ihnen.
Sorry.
Du hast ein wenig lustlos die Hände zum Tanz gehoben, aber die blieben dann doch eher relativ reglos in der Luft stecken, hatte man fast das Gefühl.
Diesen Dance-Move versucht, beide quasi wie ein Cowboy, ich ergebe mich mässig,
zwar die Hände wie ein Bilderrahmen, um mich herum in die Lüfte zu nehmen und den Kopf dazwischen herzuwackeln.
Diesen Tanz, ich weiss nicht, wie man diesen Tanz-Move nennt, das ist generell bei mir ein Problem. Ich weiß selten den Namen von Dancemoves. Ich glaube, das ist auch nicht die Priorität auf dem Dancefloor, dass du jeden der Tanzschritt genau benennen kannst. Vielleicht denke ich da schon falsch. Ich glaube, ich denke zu sehr in Sprache, mehr als dass ich in Bewegung denke. Ja, ich glaube, aber früher war das modern, dass man so ein, zwei Polizei und dann wusste jeder, ah, Polizei, drei, vier, Grenadier. Ja, auch damals schon. Da schnellte schon meine Hand in die Höhe. Entschuldigung, Entschuldigung. Ja, sorry. Ganz kurz, können die Musik? Was ist ein Grenadier? Also, das hat natürlich militärhistorisch. Es war sorry, dass ich jetzt Sie als DJ-Frage. Nein, nein, nein, völlig klar. Nein, nein, nein, ich bin offen für Fragen, immer gern. Ich habe immer noch ein Meet and Greet, Fast and Furious, Frequently Asked Questions, alles ist am Ende nochmal dran. Schön, dass du es jetzt schon mal aufmachst. Also, militärhistorisch natürlich geht es zurück auf die Granate, auch wenn nicht notwendigerweise jeder Granatier eine Granate tragen musste. Wir schauen mal kurz ins napoleonische Zeit, Alter. Und jetzt, der Krieg von Napoleon erklärt mit Hausmusik. Aber ich dachte mit Abba. Waterloo. Waterloo, Waterloo. Wir lernen nichts aus Waterloo. Nein. Ich meine, sorry, nichts jetzt irgendwie, man muss das gar nicht glorifizieren, aber wenn ich da in dieser Schlacht, also ich ist Historiker, wenn ich mich in dieser Schlacht auskennen würde, ich wäre herbe enttäuscht, wenn ich mir den Song anhören würde und nichts über diese Schlacht lernen würde. Ich wüsste nicht, was los ist. Naja. Eighteen, fifteen, Napoleon's dead. Cannons fight. Das ist ausgerechnet jetzt die Googlesuche nicht funktioniert. Oh, aber. Ah, hier. Mai Mai, at Waterloo, Napoleon did surrender. Also, das dat man schon mal, at Waterloo, Napoleon did surrender. Ich habe nie zugehört, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen. Wie viel Wissen steckt in bekannten Popsongs eigentlich? Ja, zu wenig. Also sowohl in hier Moskau, Moskau. Moskau ist eine schöne Stadt. Schöne Stadt. Werft die Gläser an die Wand. Johohoho. Warum? Wahaha rum. Da lernt man sehr viel über Moskau. Dann, wie heißt noch mal der andere Song? Rasputin von Boney M.
Ja, Lara Rasputin. Lernt man auch nicht so wahnsinnig viel. Dass der nicht sterben konnte, ne?
Die haben versucht, den umzubringen.
Eins am anderen, wir sind erst mal, Waterloo promised to love you forevermore. Waterloo couldn't escape if I wanted to. Waterloo knowing my fate is to be with you. Wawa, Wawa, Waterloo finally facing my Waterloo. Kann da mal ein Geschichtslehrer drüber gucken. Also jetzt nichts gegen Aber, aber dass man da vielleicht musikalisch Note zwei, würde ich sagen, aber Geschichte durchgefallen, würde ich sagen. History repeating. Kann man das so machen? Ich weiß es nicht. Aber es ist natürlich schwierig. Wie viel Wissen steckt eigentlich in Popsongs? Kann man ja vielleicht mal beantworten. Ich kenne mich nicht gut aus, aber vielleicht kann man ja auch viel lernen. Weil ehrlich gesagt, ich höre öfter bei der Musik nicht auf den Text. Aber das ist mir auch schon aufgefallen. Da gibt es zwei Arten von Menschen. Die einen achten sehr, sehr stark auf den Text und kommen auch über den Text. Ich komme hingegen nie über den Text. Ich komme immer nur über die Musik und freue mich dann ganz doll. Und dann sagt da jemand, hör mal, die bösen Onkels, die machen teilweise Rechtsrock, das solltest du jetzt nicht so laut hören. Das ist nicht so schön. Ja, aber du magst die Geige.
Aber ich mag einfach die Harmonien und der Dominanzept-Akkord, das ist... Ich meine, ich finde, das klingt, also, das ist ganz tolle Musik und dann auch mit den, mit viel G-Moll sieben und so und dann finde ich das rechtfertig schon hinten, mein grosser Böse Onkel-Sticker auf meinem Ford Focus. Bei mir ist es tatsächlich andersrum. Oft denke ich mir, der Song geht gut und dann fängt jemand an zu singen und ich denke mir fast, hey, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, psch, pversion, Entschuldigung, gibt es eine Instrumentalversion? Können Sie von der Bühne gehen, das ist eine Karaoke-Night. Das ist eine Karaoke-Night. Ich nehme dir den Finger aus dem Mund, der, sie will nur singen, Lena will nur singen. Okay. Dann mache ich gleich einen Song mit Instrumental-Wer-Song, okay? Hey, ja, aber Instrumental-Version, weil das sind durch, nein, hey, da sind durchaus ein paar schöne Tonfolgen drin, Leute. Sehr aggressiv. Es ist eine sehr aggressive Stimmung in dieser Karaoke-Night. Wenn Sie eine Instrumentalversion hören, dann gehen Sie nicht in eine Karaoke-Bar. Ich glaube, unsere beiden Welten können koexistieren. Frederik, wir haben das als Team-Event geplant, okay? Weil die Stimmung war nicht so gut im Büro, okay? Das haben wir gemerkt, und deswegen haben wir, die ganze Chefriege hat sich überlegt, wir machen das irgendwie eine Karaoke-Night. Ja, aber jetzt ist die Stimmung auch nicht besser. Du hast doch selber das Google-Doodle ausgefüllt. Du hättest ja auch Minigolf, Schwarzlicht-Minigolf anklicken können. Jetzt sind wir alle hier beim Karaoke, okay? Und jetzt verstehen wir nicht, warum du jetzt hier die Songs beendest, Leuten den Finger ins Gesicht steckst. Ich finde halt, die menschliche Stimme ist nicht so ausdrucksstark wie zum Beispiel eine Tuba. Sorry. Das ist eine sehr lautstarke Meinung. Das ist ein lautstarkes Instr lautstarkes Instrument, wenn man eine Tuba gehört. Das stimmt. Kannst du es vielleicht heute mal ein bisschen zurücknehmen? Manchmal ... Ich will als nächstes. Ich will als nächstes. Okay, und als nächstes Hendrik mit Rockmiamadeus und Falco. Ich wünsche mir die Mondschein-Sonate. Oh mein Gott, haben wir nicht ... Da stehe ich ganz still auf der Karaoke-Bar, ganz andächtig, wackele so ein bisschen mit ... Mit so geschlossenen Augen, das Gesicht geht in den Himmel. Muss man das auch im klassischen Konzert manchmal machen, dass man wirklich so, jetzt bin ich drin, jetzt ... Finde ich ja gut, ehrlich gesagt. Ja? Ich mag das immer, wenn man bei klassischen Konzerten Leute sieht, die Spaß haben, bei der Musik mitwippen. Ja, der mit den Stöcken in der Hand hat immer Spaß. Der hat immer viel Spaß. Der hat immer Bock. Die sind sehr invested. Nee, aber ich mag das vor allem, wenn Leute im Publikum dann auch mal mit schunkeln so ein bisschen. Aber lasst mir das Klatschen sein. Lasst mir das Klatschen sein. Nur wenn man jetzt einen Walzer spielt, den man mitklatschen könnte auf fünfzehn und siebzehn, dann ... Das war sehr anspruchsvolle Musik. Nee, das ist mir immer zuwider. Zuwider ist mir das. Ich habe auch immer, man kann irgendwie Schloss Schönbrunn oder sowas in Wien, da kann man dann ab und zu so Konzerte sich angucken. In dieser alten mozartischen Besetzung wird dann da gespielt und da spielen die halt so die Uralt-Klassiker, die alle kennen.
Was dann das Problem ist, weil alle, genau, bei allem Waterloo, weil alle mitklatschen im Publikum.
Bei diesen Walzern, es ist ganz, ganz schrecklich.
Es war kein schöner Abend.
Nicht schrecklich ist natürlich das Intro von Lenny.
So, Lenny.
Lenny hat uns schönes Intro bereitet.
Vielen, vielen Dank für Lennart.
Wissen wir nicht.
Leonhard.
Leonhard, Lennart, wir wissen nicht. Oder Lena. Er er möchte Lenny genannt werden und also nennen wir ihn Lenny. Okay, ja. Vielleicht sind wir die Ersten, die ihn Lenny nennen, vielleicht versucht er diesen Spitznamen durchzusetzen und vielleicht, wir wünschen ihm viel Erfolg, Lenny. Er spielt das jetzt gerade zu Hause seinen Freunden vor, weil er sich nicht getraut hat, zu sagen, dass er Lenny genannt werden will. Er ärgert sich, dass er jetzt acht Minuten in die Folge reinhören muss, bis wir das erste Mal seinen Namen sagen. Und er sagt, oh stimmt, Lenny nennen die mich. Der Ghetto-Blaster, in den Raum gedreht, Freunde platziert. Er hat sich nicht getraut, er hat sich die ganze Zeit im Workaround überlegt, wie sage ich den Leuten endlich, dass ich Lenny heißen will. Und er hat es jetzt geschafft mit diesem Intro. Ist das der einzige Grund für Shoutouts im Radio? Ich habe mich früher immer gefragt, warum Leute Shoutouts im Radio haben wollten. Vor allem gab es ja dann irgendwann so die Zeit, als Radiomoderatoren sehr selbstbewusst und cool wurden. Und dann so Radio 1 mässig und dann immer so dieses, ja ich wünsche mir einen Shoutout. Und dann so, nee ich mache keine Shoutouts, denn die Grüße ist der Feind des Hörers. Tschüss. Aber das hast du bei uns auch von Anfang an. Es war mit der erste Satz, den ich von dir gehört habe, zum Thema Podcasten war, aber wir machen keine Grüße. So, jetzt geht's los, erste Folge. Hallo, mein Name ist Florian Tim. Das war das Erste, was du vor der Aufnahme zu mir gesagt hast. Wir machen keine Grüße. Ja, auf jeden Fall, weil das ist natürlich auch immer so ein bisschen das Ding, wenn du einmal grüsst, musst du alle Grüße machen. Der Erzfeind des Hörers? Der Feind des Hörers, der Grüßer ist der Feind des Hörers. Grüße ist der Feind des Hörers. Grüßer, kann ich noch jemanden grüßen? Ist nicht genau das gleiche wie ein Shoutout, aber nahe dran. Der Grüßer ist der Feind des Hörers. Nice, nice, nice. Und deswegen gibt es, wir kriegen immer noch Nachrichten von Leuten, die sagen, hey, könnt ihr irgendwie meine Tante Charlotte grüssen? Und ich denke mir so, okay, wir haben jetzt 348 Folgen niemanden gegrüsst, aber Charlotte die grüssen wir. Das ist die erste, dafür lassen wir mal einen Gruß da. Ich verstehe sehr gut, warum Leute einen Shoutout wollen im Radio. Ich verstehe andere Sachen nicht. Das ist eines, was ich verstehe. Wunderbar, dass du das rauspickst als etwas, was du schon immer nicht verstanden hast. Vielleicht sind wir ja genau komplementär, dass alle Dinge, die du verstehst, verstehe ich nicht und andersrum. Seit ein paar Folgen dürfen uns beiden klar sein, dass wir beide nicht viel verstehen. Aber nee, ich glaube, das ganz klar, du willst die Massen erreichen. Und sei es nur mit deinem lächerlichen Musikwunsch, aber Waterloo. Aber warum sammeln Leute Briefmarken? Das verstehe ich dann zum Beispiel nicht. Naja, um alle zu haben. Das kann ich schon verstehen. Aber du willst Leute erreichen, du willst die Masse erreichen. Das ist ja auch wieder der Fortpflanzungstrieb des Menschen. Du willst Leute erreichen, du musst Leute, du musst deinen, wir denken alle wie Pilze, unser Alles muss in die Welt spuren. Einige Sätze, über die ich ein bisschen nachdenken muss. Ich habe immer das Gefühl, du haust deine Thesen vergleichsweise schnell raus, damit der andere gar nicht die Möglichkeit hat. Nee, aber der Mensch denkt wie Pilze. Übrigens, was wollen wir bestellen? Wer will eine Pizza? Hawaii oder nicht? Ich finde, Hawaii ist die beste Pizza. Oder wir bestellen ein paar Pizza-Brötchen und alle so. Langsam, langsam, langsam. Sorry. Pizza, Brötchen und Pizza, wirklich. Ganz kurz zurück. Habe ich aber tatsächlich nie ganz verstanden bei Bestellungen, weil es gibt Pizza, Pizzabrötchen und Pizzabrot. Und es scheint völlig selbstverständlich zu sein, dass Pizzabrötchen auch Käse und Tomaten haben, aber Pizzabrot nur Teig ist. Also habe ich zumindest so verstanden, ich habe es mir so erklären lassen am Telefon. Pizzabrot ist häufig Focaccia, was nochmal ein Curveball ist. Aber warum so? Aber es kommt immer die Pizzeria natürlich, aber ich, da wo ich meine Pizza des Vertrauens esse, ist Pizzabrot, Pizzapane eigentlich eher Focaccia, ein Pizzabrot, ein fluffiges Brot. Pizzabrötchen sind kleine Brötchen, also einfach Pizzateig, was man dann oft dippen kann, irgendwie in Aiole oder sowas. Nee, beim Pizzabrötchen sind Käse und Tomaten. Nein, doch, hundertprozentig, hundertprozentig. Bruschetta ist ... Nein, nein, nein, niemand hat von Bruschetta geredet, und ich möchte dieses Fass bitte dicht versiegelt. Das B-Wort wird weggelassen. Dicht versiegelt, hermetisch versiegelt, Bitte, nein. Niemand hat von Bruschetta geredet und ich möchte dieses Fass bitte dicht versiegelt, dicht versiegelt, hermetisch versiegelt, bitte geschlossen haben. Ja, okay, sorry. Sorry, habe ich mich voran? Pizzabrötchen ist mit Tomate und Käse. Nein, das sind Pizzarolls. Also so Paninis sagt man in der Pizzeria zum Beispiel dazu. Pizzabrötchen ist nicht immer gefüllt. Es gibt gefüllte Pizzabrötchen. Aber was ist denn der Unterschied, so wie du es jetzt erklärt hast, zwischen Pizzabrot und Pizzabrötchen? Kleine, das eine ist eine grosse, Pizzabrot ist schon massig. Das ist schon fast ein Gericht, davon kann es so satt werden. Pizzabrötchen sind eine klassische snackige Beilage zum Tücken. Also einfach die Größe, oder was ist der Unterschied? Die Portionierung, würde ich sagen. Plus der Teig ist da einfach ein anderer. Das eine ist so ein fluffiger Focaccia-Teig, das andere ist einfach ein normaler Pizzateig, halt zu kleinen Röllchen gedreht und dann gebacken.
Fortuny war noch nie so ernst interessiert an etwas wie gerade. Du stellst viele Fragen, die ich spannend finde, einfach so in den Raum und dann merke ich, das interessiert dich eigentlich gar nicht.
Doch, nee, ich bin nicht ... Aber das interessiert dich so doll.
Nee, weißt du was, ich such grad eine Telefonnummer aus und wir rufen da jetzt an. Okay, ja, rufen wir an. Wo denn jetzt? Wo rufen wir jetzt an, welche Pizzeria? Nee, das möchte ich jetzt nicht sagen. Ich habe das Gefühl, du hast jetzt deine rausgesucht, die deinen Punkt unterstützt. Moment mal, du glaubst jetzt, es gibt parteiische. Ja, na klar. Also ich werde dann gleich meine Pizzeria anrufen, damit ich meine Antwort bekomme, die ich gerne hätte.
Man kann anhand deines Trustentons erkennen, welche Nummer du wählst.
Siegfried aus Bonn, wettet.
Guten Tag.
Hallo, guten Tag, Florentin Willi hier. Ich hätte kurz eine Frage, und zwar die Pizzabrötchen auf ihrer Karte.
Sind da Tomaten und Käse mit dabei oder ist es nur Brot? Da kommt drauf an jetzt, was die für eine Bestellung machen. Es gibt normale Pizzabrötchen. Ohne alles. Dann können Sie je nach Wahl aussuchen die Pizzabrötchen. Und die normalen Pizzabrötchen, was ist da drauf? Die normalen P Pizza-Brötchen, was ist da drauf? Schau mal bitte. Die normalen Pizza-Brötchen, was ist da drauf? Äh, gar nichts. Da gibt es mit Schinken Käse, Spinat-Hirtenkäse, Tonfischkäse, Salami-Pfeffer-Oli-Käse, Hähnchen-Fleisch-Käse, also je nachdem, ne? Also Parmaschinken mit Mozzarella können Sie sich aussuchen.
Okay, alles klar, dann überlege ich nochmal. Vielen Dank. Ja, also je nach Wahl und wenn Sie jetzt sagen, ich würde mal gerne mal so eine extra Pizza brüchen, dann würde ich das einfach notieren und aus Kulanz machen. Okay, und Pizza Brot hingegen, was ist da der Unterschied? Pizza Brot? Wo haben Sie denn, welche Nummer denn? Ich hab das gar nicht vor mir gerade, ich bin hier gerade mit meinem Kollegen Stefan, aber also Pizzabrot gibt es nicht, es gibt nur Brötchen. Pizzabrotchen, das ist wie Brot, so wie Sie es gesagt haben, da ist nichts drin, ne? Alles klar, okay. Kann man da mit Kräuterbutter oder mit Aioli ein bisschen mitessen? Wunderbar, alles klar, dann beraten wir uns nochmal und dann... Einfach leer. Alles klar, perfekt. Ansonsten kann ich was zu Sie extra vorbereiten lassen. Okay, super, vielen Dank. Dann überlegen wir uns das nochmal. Dankeschön, vielen Dank für die Information. Ja, bitte schön. Tschüss. Casual Name Drop. Ich bin mit meinem Kollegen Stefan da. Vielen Dank für die Grüße an der Stelle. Ich wollte einen kleinen Shoutout da lassen für dich, weil ich wusste, dass es dir so viel bedeutet. Ja, vielen Dank. Hast du eine Privatnummer einfach angerufen? Weil die wirkten nicht so, als ob sie darauf vorbereitet sind, dass Leute anrufen, weil sehr viel Geräusch im Hintergrund waren. Ich habe tatsächlich in meiner Recherche, bin ich bei einem Pizzaladen gelandet und habe dann auf Impressum geklickt. Ja. Und habe dann da angerufen. Ich weiß nicht, ob das jetzt irgendwie illegal ist. Naja, egal. Also wir haben es geklärt. Sag es, sag es.
Sorry.
Nee.
Normalerweise willst du immer, dass ich mich entschuldige, wenn du mich so ansprichst.
Das stimmt, sag es.
Du hast mich konditioniert.
Sag es.
Daddy?
Nee, das nicht.
Du hattest recht.
Du hattest recht, ja.
Und jetzt musst du mich aber belohnen.
Hast du nicht gesagt, dass du immer Leute belohnst, wenn sie sagen, sie haben recht? Wie so ein Hund. Er kriegt so ein paar. Zärtlich auf die Wange getappt. Getappt. Dankeschön. Ne? Jetzt fühle ich mich gut. Jetzt weiß ich gar nicht warum. Nö, ist ja kein Problem. Ja, du hattest recht. Okay. Ja, also, ja. Es gibt Pizzabrot, aber eher selten. Es gibt Pizzabrötchen, die sind meistens ungefüllt. Deswegen immer lieber gefüllte Pizzabrötchen, dann direkt mit was ihr das wollt. Kannst du mit diesen Durchmesser-Zentimeterangaben was anfangen? Inzwischen schon. Ja? Inzwischen schon. Inzwischen würde ich sagen, 28 ist Standard, 36 ist insane und alles unter 28 werde ich nicht satt von. Okay. Alles klar. Aber es ist nicht die Grösse entscheidend, sondern wie man es ist. Ach so, ja, das stimmt. Was man belegt, also was man draufhaut. Und da schätzt man nicht die Dinge, die man draufpackt. Also wenn man da irgendwie eine Quadro Stagioni völlig eskaliert, dann reicht auch eine kleine Pizza vielleicht. Wohingegen... Also du... Klingt ja fast so, als würdest du sagen, dass der Durchmesser alleine nicht ausreicht, sondern das Volumen quasi eigentlich eher ausschlaggebend ist. Das ist, was ich sagen will. Dass das eine rein zweidimensionale Betrachtung ist, wenn du nur den Durchmesser angibst. Eigentlich redest du ja eher von Kubikzentimetern, wenn die noch weniger durchsichtig sind. Ich bräuchte eine dreidimensionale Tabelle. Also quasi
S, M und L.
P, I und Z. Und dann noch quasi
in der Tiefe dann auch noch mal
in welcher, okay, welches Volumen
wollen Sie, also welche, hallo, herzlich willkommen
bei 3D Pizza, schönen guten Tag.
Hallo, guten Tag, Pizza Passa, hallo, guten Tag, was kann ich für Sie tun?
Nee, umgekehrt, hallo bei 3D Pizza,
herzlich willkommen, was kann ich für Sie tun?
Ja, ich hab Sie bei mir angerufen. Ich hab Ihren Flyer nicht ganz verstanden. Die meisten Leute üben im Kopf, was sie sagen wollen, bevor sie irgendwo anrufen. Haben wir das nicht gemacht? Ja, wissen Sie, ich habe das mit meinem Kumpel gerade geübt und ich war immer der, der... Haben Sie sich vertan. Ich war immer der, der den Pizza-Service gespielt hat. Das war ich ein bisschen verwirrt, weil ich habe jetzt mit der falschen Rolle im Kopf anrufen. Sie sind bei 3D-Pizza gelandet. Okay, gut, dann fangen wir nochmal an. Gut, ab jetzt. Hallo, herzlich willkommen bei 3D-Pizza, was kann ich für Sie tun? Ich war ein bisschen verwirrt von Ihrem Flyer. Kein Problem. Erstmal, Ihr Flyer wurde bei meinem Nachbarn abgegeben, weil er anscheinend nicht in meinen Briefkasten gepasst hat. Wie gefällt Ihnen unser Flyer? Deswegen ich extra bei meinem Nachbarn anklopfen musste für den Flyer. Der ist einfach riesengroß. Aber haben Sie ihn aufgeklappt, da kommt so ein 3D-Bild raus. Genau deswegen, Briefkästen sind nicht dafür gedacht für dreidimensionale Objekte. Okay, ist das schon ein Feedback-Teil des Gesprächs oder wollen Sie noch bestellen? Naja, also ich wollte erstmal nur zur Klärung anrufen, ich rufe noch nicht an für die Pizza. Margarita, Francesco, do you solo? No, andiamo, andiamo! Sorry. Also was meinen Sie mit 3D-Pizza? Ich verstehe nicht genau. For the Tato! For the Tate, for the Tate! Oh, Maria, for the Tato! Ci tre dimensione, tre dimensione! Drette dimensione, tre! Sorry, scusi. Okay, ist es gerade unpassend oder soll ich woanders nochmal antworten?? Nein, es ist der beste Zeitpunkt. Wirklich? Alles andere Zeitpunkte, wenn noch schlechter. Wirklich? Wie fragen Sie sich? Okay, gut. Versuchen Sie es doch mal später. Also ich habe nicht ganz verstanden, was Sie mit 3D-Pizza meinen. Okay, also erst mal, wie groß soll die Pizza sein im Durchmesser? Wollen Sie die S, die M oder die L? Die M wäre 28, die L wäre 36 cm.
Quadratzentimeter.
Quadratzentimeter, ich bin so schlecht mit Zahlen.
Nein, der Durchmesser ist 28 bei der M.
Ja, wie gross ist ein Lenkrad ungefähr?
Also ich kann mir da jetzt runter gar nichts vorstellen.
Wie? Welche bestreite Lenkrad? Wie gross ist ein Gullideckel?
Oh, Gullideckel ist grösser. Okay. 55. 55? Ja. Dann nehme ich die M. Die M, okay, ja, das ist der Klassiker, der ist ja beliebt. So wollen Sie das in der, jetzt ist die Frage, weil deswegen 3D-Pizza, wir bieten auch verschiedene Volumen an. So, jetzt müssen Sie quasi in die Tiefe denken. Wollen Sie hier S ...
In die Höhe, oder?
Ja, genau.
Wollen Sie hier in die S, M oder L?
Also ich habe Fläche M.
S wäre 28
Kubikzentimeter,
M wäre 35
Kubikzentimeter.
Judith!
Oder L? Judith!
Wie viel Hunger hast du?
Was bedeutet das?
Sie schüttelt
ihre Hand so in der Mitte. Wie?
Judith, aber am Ende willst du immer mehr.
Judith, du kannst
mit mir reden.
Okay.
Dann lass uns mal in der Höhe
richtig auf... Kann ich mal mit ihrer Frau sprechen?
Schatz?
Der will mit dir sprechen. Der will mit dir sprechen. Ich weiß auch nicht, ich weiß auch nicht, warum. Ich möchte gerne kurz mit Ihrer Frau sprechen. Ja, hier ist Judith. Hi, alles gut bei Ihnen zu Hause? Ihr Mann hat so komisch mit Ihnen gesprochen, dass ich kurz fragen wollte, ob bei Ihnen alles okay ist. Ja, es dauert halt immer ein bisschen lange mit der Bestellung, weil er immer irgendwie bei dem neuen... Aber er schreit sie an, er ruft die ganze Zeit, er ruft zu bestimmen, Judith, Judith, Judith. Deswegen wollte ich einfach nur fragen, ob alles gut ist. Es ist nur weit weg. Wir sind im Hobbykeller. Ich hätte mir Sorgen gemacht, dass irgendwie was nicht stimmt. Ach, das ist nett von Ihnen. Ja, dafür sind wir da. Okay. Alles gut. Ist bei Ihnen alles in Ordnung? Nein. Nein? Nein. 3D-Pizza läuft überhaupt nicht. Niemand bestellt hier, niemand blickt da durch. Ich blick doch selber nicht durch. Niemand kann was mit Kubikzentimeter anfangen. Schreiben Sie doch auf Ihre Karte einfach so was wie Lenkrad oder Gulli oder zwei Euro Stück oder so was als Referenz so was in der Richtung. Ich dachte, das wäre eine gute Idee, weil man, auch in einer kleinen Pizza wird man satt, wenn sie noch viel belegt ist. Wenn sie höher ist, ja. Wenn sie höher ist quasi. Okay, ich möchte ihrem Konzept vertrauen, dann nehmen wir eine S-Pizza in Fläche, aber XL in Höhe. Okay, das wären dann 65 Kubikzentimeter. Von mir aus.
Vergleichbar mit
so einem schönen,
so einem Tischweihnachtsbaum.
Kennen Sie den?
Okay.
Sie müssen wirklich dringend an ihren Referenzen arbeiten.
Aber ich freue mich auf die Pizza.
Sie kommt kalt an.
Jochen!
Wahrscheinlich kommt sie kalt an.
Jochen! Jochen! Komm her! Ich gebe Ihnen wieder Jochen. Was für eine merkwürdige Wohnung. Eine Schlauchwohnung. Eine sehr lange und auch hier ist die Frage, wie viel Quadratmeter hat diese Wohnung? Das Ehepaar wusste es nicht. Das ist doch eine weitere Sketch-Ebene, eine weitere Humorebene dieses Sketches, ist, dass die Quadratmeterfläche dieser Wohnung seltsam war. Naja, ich habe mich schon gewundert, dass der Makler immer nur von Kubikmeter gesprochen hat. Unklar war, dass er einmal einmal hundertzwanzig Meter, wir leben in einem umgestürzten Schornstein, der jetzt zu einer Mietwohnung gemacht wird. Besser so als aufrecht, wo die Kubikmeteranzahl exakt die gleiche wäre, aber unwohnlicher. Genau so hat der Vermieter auch argumentiert, komischerweise. Der sagte, seien Sie froh, dass er nicht noch steht. Seien Sie froh, dass grosse Deutzer Schornstein-Katastrophe passiert ist und der umgefallen ist. So können Sie drin wohnen. So können Sie drin wohnen. Nehmen Sie Bowling. Sie können einen Pin auf der ganz anderen Seite aufstellen und dann wegbauen. Aber nur einen einzigen. Für alles andere wäre die Breite nicht da. Ja, keine Ahnung, ich weiß es nicht, ich hatte Recht. Das ist richtig, du hattest Recht. Aber ich weiß auch nicht, mit welchem Grad, weil du hast auch Recht, es ist ein bisschen verwirrend, es gibt Pizza und Brot und das hat uns jetzt nicht abschließend gehalten. Einfach Bilder, einfach Bilder. Bei Sushi bin ich jedes Mal verwirrt, Takamori, Soshimi, jedes Mal, was ist das, wild drauf los, wir lernen es nicht. Oder mal ausprobieren, probiert doch mal aus. Ihr werdet nicht überrascht von neuen tollen kleinen Dingen. Immer gerne. Apropos Bowling, wir sind ja natürlich große Sportfans, schauen natürlich gerade auch wieder Drive to Survive, ist klar, aber jetzt kam auch, wie es ja schon vor langem angekündigt hat, die neue Golf-Doku. Nein, nein, und ich bin riesen Golf-Fan. Oje. Ich liebe Golf. Wo schaust du das? Ich liebe Golf auf Netflix. Netflix kann man jetzt natürlich auch, falls ihr dachtet, Formel 1 ist cool, dann schaut euch jetzt die Golf-Doku an und ich bin jetzt riesen Golf-Fan, ich kenne alle Spieler und es ist fantastisch. Aber es ist ein bisschen alberner Sport, muss man schon sagen. Okay, führen Sie uns mal ein bisschen durch, was das genau der Faszination anbelangt. Weil für mich ist es, ich habe es jetzt ein paar Mal gemacht, es macht Spaß, man läuft rum, es ist eine tolle Sonntagsaktivität, man kann halt einfach an der frischen Luft langsam herumlaufen, denkt dabei, man würde sowas wie Sport machen, freut sich danach aber prima auf die Drinks und das Essen. Jetzt finde ich das zum Gucken, glaube ich, anderen Leuten dabei zuzugucken, finde ich glaube, nicht so spannend. Die Sache ist die, es ist immer schwer, in Sport einzusteigen, weil du weißt nicht, was ist gut oder schlecht, was ist eine gute Leistung. Also ich habe mal Snooker geschaut und er hat eine Kugel reingehauen und ich bin ausgerastet, habe mich gefreut, wohingegen, wenn du ein erfahrener Snooker-Zuschauer bist, ist das irrelevant. Also du willst nicht der Einzige im Stadion sein, der sagt, wow, gibst ihm, yes! Nee, der macht immer so zwölf bis dreizehn Kugeln pro. Ah, okay. Ach so, okay. Und beim Golf ist es ganz gut, weil du kannst immer direkt am Gesicht des Golfspielers ablesen, ob das ein guter Schlag war oder nicht. Weil das Geile an Golf ist, du siehst ja den Schlag selbst nicht. Also der schlägt mit voller Wucht, also die haben teilweise, also vielleicht Aggressionsprobleme, meiner Meinung nach, sorry, Hot Take, aber die schlagen mit einer Wucht auf diesen Golfball und dann sieht man nichts. Und dann kann man eigentlich nur dem Golfspieler ins Gesicht gucken, wie er so ... Links, links, links, links, links!
Ah, okay, das war nicht ...
Nicht links genug.
Auch wenn niemand den Ball selbst sieht, kann man so einfach immer sehen, ob der Schlag einfach auch. Und das ist für mich als Einsteiger immer super hilfreich, weil ich schaue dem Golfer einfach nur in die Augen und merke, er ist richtig unzufrieden gerade. Er ist auch geblendet teilweise und sieht wahrscheinlich den Ball selber auch nicht, ist meine Theorie. Die sehen den Ball selber auch nicht. Naja, ist auf Weiß, also keine gute Farbe, gen Himmel, es ist eine gute Farbe gen Gras. Oder, wie wir früher als Kinder hatten, mit so einer Pfeife dran. Es gab immer diese... So wird man auch nicht getroffen dann. Gib das doch mal einem Golfball. Und jeder sieht so ... Super. Und jeder weiß sofort, geil, wo ist er, du kannst das Geräusch hören, inklusiv, blinde Leute können zuschauen, ist perfekt. Ja, finde ich auch super. Blinde Leute haben wahrscheinlich auch viel Spaß beim Golfschauen. Ich weiß es nicht. Meine Antwort auf die Frage, warum warum Sportarten zu schauen anhand von Zugänglichkeit im Sinne von war das ein guter Schlag oder nicht, Kommentatoren.
Kommentatoren helfen natürlich ungemein. Ja. Ich habe jetzt auch wieder angefangen, Battlebots zu schauen ein bisschen.
Ich weiss auch immer nicht genau, war das jetzt gut oder schlecht, wobei da die Regeln
denkbar überschaubar sind und man schon relativ gut merkt, welcher Robot gerade die, ähm, upper hand halt,
aber Kombinatoren helfen einfach sehr.
Ja.
Die sagen dir, was gut war, was nicht gut war, und anhand der Emotionen checkst du auch, wie schlecht, wie viel zu schlecht das jetzt war oder wie viel zu gut das war.
Von daher, das hilft. Aber Golf, weiß ich nicht, komm ich da rein?
Ich weiß es auch nicht, es ist natürlich so,
es gibt natürlich so zwei Arten von Sportarten,
es gibt so die Sportarten, wo man so gegeneinander spielt,
und dann gibt es Sportarten, wo einfach so jeder
so sein Ding macht. Aber schon noch gegeneinander beim Golfen.
Nicht wirklich, weil jeder
macht sein Ding, so wie Bogenschießen,
du schießt halt alleine, es ist nicht so, dass der Gegner
versucht, mit seinem Pfeil, deinem Pfeil in der Luft
abzuschießen oder irgendwie so, sondern du machst
dein Ding und denkst halt, ja, heute war ich schlecht, oh, heute war ich gut, ich habe gewonnen, so heute war ich schlecht, so du machst dein Ding und das ist immer so ein bisschen schwierig. Das stimmt, das sind diese Halbgegeneinander-Sportarten, wo nur der Ort. Du machst gleichzeitig dasselbe, aber du spielst nicht wirklich gegeneinander. Man wechselt sich auch so nett ab. Ja. Und irgendwie zählt allein der Ort, der macht es dann zum Gegeneinander. Ja, genau. Weil dann, das stellt eine Vergleichbarkeit her. Ja, und halt so ein bisschen Druck. Es gibt schon, wenn am Ende zwei den gleichen Punktestand haben, müssen die nochmal zu zweit nochmal anfangen. Die machen dann weniger Löcher, aber spielen zu zweit, solange bis ein Ergebnis dasteht. Aber wenn jetzt Greg spielt gegen Tom. Ja, so, und Greg hat gewonnen gegen Tom auf der gleichen Bahn vor einem Jahr mit Abstand. Und jetzt verliert er aber nur ganz knapp. Ja. Dann fühle ich mich als Greg trotzdem besser, weil ich ihn an der gleichen Bahn vor einem Jahr bei der exakt dem gleichen mal besiegt habe. Weißt du, deswegen meine ich, es ist nicht gegeneinander racen zum Beispiel, wo du, das ist ja nicht, du hast ja ein Rennen ist mit dem anderen nicht vergleichbar, aber du spielst ja gegen dich selber die exakt gleiche Bahn. Und du weißt, ich bin einfach schlechter geworden. Früher habe ich das in 15 Schlägen gemacht, heute 908. So, das passiert manchmal. Das ist das Allerdemütigste, wenn die beim, ganz am Ende beim Patten, mehrmals das Loch nicht treffen. Und wenn die dann einfach schon so fucking wütend sind. Und das ist dann immer so dieses, du hast diese wohlgesittete Golffeld und du hast den Typen, der mit seinem Schläger einfach, er hat nichts, was er schlagen kann, er haut dann so auf die Wiese und so und ist dann so, warning. Oh, wer sagt warning? Ich weiß es nicht, irgendjemand sagt dann, warning, warning, warning what? Nichts, du kannst nichts gegen mich tun, es gibt keine Regeln, einfach keine Regeln, aber es ist wirklich grossartig. Und natürlich bin ich jetzt auch im Golf-Hype, will jetzt auch golfen, wer es aber wahrscheinlich nicht tun. Aber ich träume davon, Golfer zu sein. Wollen wir mal eine Runde über den Golfplatz gehen? Gehen? Wir sind beide Caddy. Wir tragen beide unsere Schläger. Was man nämlich hier in Köln machen kann, hier gibt es nämlich eine Bahn, weil die normalen Bahnen sind für uns lächerlich, kriegen wir nicht hin, die sind viel zu lang, das Loch ist viel zu weit entfernt, das wäre absolute Tortur für uns beide, aber es gibt diesen Kinderkurs, das ist so eine B-Ranch. Es ist eins über Minigolf, es ist Maxigolf. Es ist schon, also du hast zwar die Kinderschläge und du hast auch den Tabaluga-Ball, ja, aber es ist trotzdemsser. Genau. Können wir gerne auch machen. Das ist so eine B-Runde und die hat so 60 Meter wahrscheinlich bis zum Loch. Also ist schon anspruchsvoll und so. Du musst schon richtig ausholen und richtig durchziehen für uns, weil sonst würden wir diese Länge nicht hinbekommen. Aber du haust jetzt nicht mit diesem dicken Eisen da rein, sondern mit diesem kleinen Eisen. Aber es ist schon auch kein Minigaufschläger. Das können wir mal machen. Und ich glaube, wir sind da nicht so schlecht drin vielleicht. Machen wir wieder Fit Can auch Lustig dieses Jahr, Fit Can auch Lustig 23, wieder schön Golf. Du droppst das so casual, als wäre das ein großer Erfolg von 2019 gewesen. Wo wir einmal Padel gespielt haben im Jahr 2019. Das hat mich fit gehalten über Jahre hinweg, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen. Mein Körper, es ist ja immer so, Fitness ist ja nur relativ, also wenn du komplett brach liegst. Es geht eigentlich. Wenn du komplett brach liegst, dann kann ja einmal einen Sportnachmittag kann dich ja schon im Durchschnitt die nächsten fünf Jahre tragen. Du darfst nur nicht zu viel Sport machen, sonst ist dein Standard zu hoch. Ich glaube, das ist vieles Mindset, was sich davon abhält, überhaupt dich zu bewegen. Ja, das mag sein. Aber ja, also, Fitt kann auch lustig, war unsere große Erfolgsinitiative 2019, wo wir bei Badminton spielen wollten. Ach ja, stimmt. Das ist noch länger her und das haben wir nie gemacht. Wir wollten dann auch mal ein Community-Turnier machen, was auch immer. Deswegen, wir ersparen euch jetzt mal quasi dieses Prospect. Wie naiv. Wie doof und naiv. Aber wir können jetzt, wird genau lustig, Golf finde ich nicht schlecht. Ja, man passt sich an den körperlichen Gegebenheiten so ein bisschen. Wird genau lustig, Schach auch nicht schlecht. Ja. Dass wir uns nicht überarbeiten, nicht überheben. Nein, nein, das auf keinen Fall. Finde ich gut. Aber ich bin sehr gespannt, wie lange diese Phase anhält. Du glechst dich ein bisschen den Phasen an und vielleicht löse ich mich langsam ein bisschen davon. Vielleicht werden wir... Ich glaube, das ist mein Deir ist meines Lebens. Ist jetzt einfach Golf. Ist jetzt einfach Golf? Okay, spannend. Ist einfach Golf. Ich habe gehört, da werden immer die besten Verträge geschlossen und sowas in der Richtung. Deswegen finde ich es eine gute Sache. Ja, Draft2 Survive kommt jetzt auch die neue Staffel raus, ist glaube ich schon jetzt wieder raus,
da habe ich nur viel Kritik gehört, ich habe nämlich, wie wir beim TikTok-Reel durchschauen, Lando Norris, der Fahrer, hat dann... Nicht Spoiler, ne, bitte jetzt. Hat auf manche Clips reagiert, manche Spicy Clips, und offensichtlich nehmen die einfach falsche Radioschnipsel, die sie über Funk durchgeben, damit eine Rivalry oder sowas größer gemacht wird, als sie eigentlich war. Das heißt, ja, na ja, nee, also Dreyfus-Verweifel war immer realitätsnah und es war wirklich, der Sport war insane, es gab ein paar wirklich spannende Jahre jetzt. Und jetzt die neue Staffel muss natürlich wieder genau das gleiche leisten, jetzt war die Saison aber nicht so spannend. Hör auf, du darfst nicht spoilern! Nee, sei, weiter nicht. Ich bin doch nicht durch. Ja, ich weiß auch nicht, ich war auch nicht reingeguckt, ich weiß, wie die Saison war und das ist ja nicht jedes Jahr, im letzten Rennen entscheidet sich alles und deswegen, ne? Aber die müssen natürlich, die Macher wollen natürlich trotzdem
irgendwie es hinbekommen, dass es wieder genauso
spannend wird. Also sag ich mal, wird
hier ein bisschen mehr gespeist, mit mehr
Gewürz gehandhabt, was eigentlich
da ist. Ja, das will ich gar nicht
wissen. Ich will gar nicht den Zaubertrick erklärt bekommen.
Ich will das alles glauben. Lass mich in meiner
Traumwelt. In einer naiven kleinen Traumwelt, okay.
Ich bin jetzt noch ein bisschen durch die Heimwerke gegangen.
Ich habe jetzt ein kleines Heimwerke-Projekt für mich entdeckt. Aquarium, bitte kein Aquarium. Hat man vielleicht gesehen bei der Rocket Beans TV Referate Show, wo ich das Ganze vorgestellt habe, weil ich habe einen schönen Berg gebaut. Nein. Und dafür bin ich unter die Heimwerke gegangen und ich war in vielen Baumärkten unterwegs. Wie einen Berg gebaut? Ich habe einen Berg aus Styrodur gebaut. Styrodur. Ja, so Isoliermittel, so Schaumstoff, und habe das bearbeitet in einem schönen Berg. Ich kann es leider noch nicht genau sagen, weil ich nicht weiß, wie es am Ende aussieht, weil es eine absolute Katastrophe ist. Ein paar Fragen, warum Berg? Weil mein Referatsthema was mit Bergen zu tun hat und ich deswegen das demonstrieren wollte. Aber es klingt jetzt schon für mich so, ohne ein Referat gehört zu haben, dass du kompensieren musstest mit fehlendem Inhalt. Hundertprozentig, absolut. Mein Ziel war, ich will was bauen dieses Mal. Und mir wäre eigentlich egal gewesen, welches Thema es wäre. Ich wusste nur, dass ich was bauen will. Weil es gibt dieses unfassbar geile Video, das ich wirklich einmal im Monat anschaue, wo irgend so ein kanadischer Küsteningenieur, der hat so einen grossen Wasserkasten. Und dann gibt es auf einer Seite immer so eine Flosse, die immer so Wasser hin und her wackelt, sodass Wellen entstehen. Und dann demonstriert er verschiedene Arten Küsten vor Wellen zu schützen, weil der grösste Feind der Küste ist die Welle natürlich, ironie des Schicksals, die leben zusammen. Da ist die am meisten vorhanden. zusammen und die haben dann so verschiedene Mauern gebaut, um die Wellen aufzuhalten. Also dann gibt es so Unterwasser, so Steine oder unterwasser eine Mauer oder überwasser eine Mauer oder überwasser eine Mauer, die so schräg ist und so. Und dann macht er immer seinen Kasten an und dann so drei Wellen. Und dann sagt er immer, ah, jetzt ist 100 Milliliter Wasser über den Küstenwall gegangen. Und dann setzt er was anderes ein. Und du kannst immer selber mitraten, ist das jetzt besser oder schlechter als das davor? Und es stellt sich raus, dass ich es nicht geschafft habe, in einer Woche das gleich zu machen, was professionelle Ingenieure und Architekten so hinkriegen mit ihrer Demonstration. Aber ich war in vielen Baumärkten und ich liebe Baumärkte und Baumärkte machen richtig Spaß.
Ja, finde ich auch.
Aber bist du nicht sogar, hättest du dafür nicht sogar in so einen Hobbyhandel, in so einen Modellbauhandel gehen müssen? Ja, komm da mal rein. Die sind mega, weil die sind noch ein bisschen besser als Baumärkte. Ja, aber es ist auch tatsächlich so ein Ding, man ist ja tatsächlich mittlerweile als Internet-User, und das sind wir ja beide, sorry, aber man ist ja sehr Amazon verwöhnt, muss man sagen. Nee, muss man sagen.
Wenn du normal bei Amazon bestellst, wirkt jeder andere Online-Versand einfach wie ein kompletter Saftler.
Wie ein Rip-Off. Wie ein Rip-Off, musst du einfach sagen. Und dann war ich auf so einem Modellbau-Online-Shop und dann wollte ich da halt so Kunstschnee bestellen. Und während des gesamten Bestellprozesses auf der gesamten Website wurde nicht ein einziges Mal mit einer Silbe auch nur annähernd erwähnt, wann das Zeug kommt. Nie! Bei Amazon ist das Erste, was da steht, er kommt bei dir am 23.04. an. Auf dieser Modellbauseite nichts. Das heißt, ich habe einfach ins Schwarze hinein bestellt. Gut Glück, vielleicht kommt es dieses Jahr an, vielleicht morgen, vielleicht drei Wochen nach dem Referat kommt es an. Nichts dergleichen. Selbst ich dachte ja, aber am Ende steht dann, ja, rechnen Sie mit den Bestellungen in so und so vielen Tagen? Nee. Der lässt sich einfach komplett alleine. Und das ist wirklich eine Katastrophe. Aber es ist so lustig, weil inzwischen selbst so sehr seriöse Online-Händler werden von mir nicht mehr frequentiert, weil ich die unseriös finde. Weil, also selbst so Otto.de oder so, was so früher der Quelle-Katalog war, aber so ganz normale Websites finde ich unseriös und scammy. Weil das ist alles nicht Amazon, das ist alles nicht mein Zuhause, das ist so merkwürdig. Es ist total unfair und ich denke mir immer, nee, komm, bestell mal woanders, bestell mal woanders, unterstützt mal irgendwie so einen kleinen Hobbyladen oder so, aber der hilft dir halt einfach gar nichts. Das ist einfach so, Entschuldigung, wie gross sind denn die Modellbäume? Wie, Sie können doch nicht einfach mit den Schultern zucken. Reden Sie mit mir, hallo, schauen Sie sich an, schauen Sie mir die Augen. Wie viele Modellbäume sind denn in der Packung drin? Ich habe mein Haus in Lego nachgebaut. Habe ich dir das mal erzählt? Ich weiß nicht, ob ich es hier schon mal erzählt habe, aber ich habe das Haus, in dem ich wohne, mit Lego nachgebaut. Und das war ein Projekt vor ein paar Monaten von mir. Hat sehr viel Spaß gemacht. Hast du auch dich als Figur?
Nee, ich habe mich nicht gebaut.
Ist es in dem Maßstab, dass eine Lego-Figur so ein großes Figur bleibt?
Nee, es ist nicht in Minifiguren-Massstab.
Es ist auch innen drin nicht im Maßstab.
Es ist halt ein Fassadenmodell.
Einer meiner Nachbarn ist Architekt, der hat mir das dann erklärt,
der war der größte Fan davon.
Es hat sehr viel Spaß gemacht, das war ein richtig cooles Projekt.
Und dafür habe ich mir dann auch ganz viele Sachen bestellen müssen. Und das war auch so ein unseriöses, ich meine, das war insane, dass es so gut ging, weil ich habe dann so ein Programm gehabt, damit habe ich dann das Modell gebaut und dann konnte man oben quasi alle Teile, die man benutzt hat dafür, konnte man dann in einen Warenkorb packen, das ist dann so ein Link gewesen, den konnte ich klicken und dann bin ich auf Bricklink gelandet, einer Website, die gebrauchte Legosteine verkauft und dann wurde halt meine ganze, alle Teile, die ich brauchte, das waren so um die tausend, zweieinhalb Teile, die ich dafür brauchte, wurden dann verteilt auf die verschiedenen Händler, die gerade anbieten, diese speziellen Teile. Das war richtig cool gemacht und da stand aber auch nirgendwo die Lieferzeit drin, aber die haben sich alle richtig viel Mühe gegeben und dann kamen ganz schnell, kamen dann aus der ganzen aus ganz Deutschland so verschiedene Teile zugeschickt, da haben ganz viele Pakete bekommen. Wirkt wahrscheinlich auch ein bisschen verdächtig, oder? Das ist so eine klassische Drogenbestellung bei 20 verschiedenen Versandseiten. Exakt, und es sieht auch Sandwand, und ich habe ja damals auch zu Recherchezwecken für die Serie, für die ich geschrieben habe, habe ich ja auch Drogen bestellt im Darknet. Und es waren exakt die gleichen Umschläge, es waren exakt auch die gleichen Verpackungen innen drin, diese kleinen Plastiktüten, wo dann die Steine drin waren. Es war genau das gleiche, nur ohne zusammengeknülltes Papier, damit es nicht ertastbar ist.
Bei Drogen haben die noch immer
Papier reingemacht, damit man
die Drogen nicht erfüllen kann.
So, und jetzt pass auf.
Cracklink.
Du verkaufst es wie ein kompletter
Lego-Shop, aber jeder weiss, dass
es eigentlich Drogen sind, und am Ende
musst du die Legosteine dann so zerdrücken,
um das Pulver zu kriegen.
Cracklink, if you know, you know.
So heißt die Website, Cracklink.
Wenn du wissen, die dann bei fucking da ihre dreimal zweierteils besuchen. Ja, aber Cracklink, with us, you can build high. The higher you get, the harder you fall. Ja, aber finde ich eine gute Idee, weil es ist, glaube ich, einfach nicht zu überprüfen. Ich glaube, der einzige Grund, warum nicht schon längst alle Drogenhändler aufgefallen sind im Internet, ist halt, weil es auch Leute gibt, die einfach Legosteine verschicken. Das ist, glaube ich, nicht auseinanderzuhalten. Die Polizei kann nicht bei jedem die Tür eintreten, der sich irgendwie so diese kleinen Köpfe von Legomännchen gekauft hat. Die heissen auch dann genauso dubios, so Globetrack oder Globlogistics und so was. Halt genau diese ausgedachten Firmennamen, die mir als falscher Absender auf den Drogen riefen. Ja, also das war nicht, es hat sehr viel Spaß gemacht, das zu bauen und dann ja, habe ich das erstellt und inzwischen habe ich mir auch schon Lichter gekauft, quasi für Innenbeleuchtung. Kannst du dann in diese Wohnung auch so eine Figur reinbauen, die wiederum ein Modell baut? Ja, sehr gut. Aus so Legosteinen? Sehr schön, finde ich sehr gut. Das finde ich sehr witzig. Das finde ich schön. Dass es immer weiter reingeht. Ja, ja, ja. Das finde ich sehr gut, ja. Es hat sehr viel Spaß gemacht, aber ich stelle mir das genauso vor, wie du dann zu Hause dich in deinem Projekt verwirklichst.
Ich finde das sehr gut. Ich finde es gut, dass wir beide so alte Mann-Projekte haben, so Hobbykeller. Ja, man braucht das so ein bisschen, aber für mich ist es auch immer nur eine Ausrede, um einfach in den Baumarkt zu gehen.
Ich bin da so gerne. Ich glaube auch, dass wenn im Baumarkt man nichts kaufen könnte, würden Leute trotzdem in den Baumarkt gehen.
Ja.
Einfach weil man kann da so reinknautschen überall, man kann das so anfassen, man kann so richtig fachmännisch über so ein Holzbrett streichen und sagen so, ach ja. Keine Ahnung, nichts. Haben sie es auch in Dicker? Und dann kannst du dich einfach mal so richtig wie so ein Heimwerker fühlen, obwohl am Ende einfach irgendwie nur so ein, ich habe eigentlich, mein Problem ist immer, ich weiß nicht, wie die Werkzeuge heißen, die ich suche. Ja,e. Ich gehe in den Baumarkt und sage, ich werde es schon finden. Und dann ist ja die Frage, gibt man sich jetzt die Blöße und geht zu einem Mitarbeiter hin und sagt, passen Sie auf. Mein Selbstbewusstsein, ich gebe es Ihnen. Wir müssen jetzt gar nicht so tun, als wäre ich hier irgendwie ein Heimwerker oder ein echter Mann oder sowas in der Richtung. Lass uns das einfach direkt skippen. Ich bin ein erbärmlicher Wurm, ich habe noch nie was gebaut in meinem Leben. Das grösste Projekt bis jetzt war ein Ikea-Schrank, okay? Sind wir uns einig, sind wir da? Sie können mir einfach sagen, was Sie brauchen, Sir. Stopp, stopp, stopp, Ihr Anspruch ist immer noch zu hoch. Nee, ich habe keinen Anspruch. Nehmen Sie den Anspruch? Hier kommen jeden Tag 10.000 Leute rein, die mich ... Herr Goldfinger. Ja, Goldfinger. Nehmen Sie den Anspruch und drücken Sie ihn noch weiter nach unten. Der Bund-Bösewicht. Fast, aber nur fast. Mein Name ist Goldfinger. Goldfinger. Ja, Goldfinger. Ja, nehmen Sie den Anspruch und drücken Sie ihn noch unten. Ja, habe ich ja gerade gesagt. Stopp, stopp, stopp, da geht noch mehr. Ich verstehe nur nicht, warum... Sie können mit der Erwartungshaltung an meine Kompetenz immer noch ein Stückchen nach unten drücken. Okay, okay. Sie haben Sägespäne im Gesicht. Ja, und das sollte Sie nicht überraschen. Ich wollte Sie... Das sollte... Stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp,en. Was ich suche und jetzt, ich weiß, ich werde das falsche Wort sagen, ich werde dabei die falsche Handbewegung machen, ich werde dabei dumm aussehen und Sie werden sich denken, was für ein Vollidiot.
Wie ist der Name? Ich bin Jochen.
Jochen. Mein Name ist Patrick Goldfinger, okay?
Okay. Jochen, pass auf. Es muss ja nicht peinlich sein. Niemand, der hier reinkommt, ist ein echter Mann. Okay. Okay? N aus. Wir alle laufen hier rum, tun wichtig, grummeln vor uns CD17, die Dübel aus der 19. Nein, das ist alles egal. Sie haben auch keine Ahnung. Wir haben alle keine Ahnung. Ich schon, ich arbeite lange hier. Ich bin ein echter Mann. Okay, nicht, dass Sie das sich da vertun, aber ich wollte nur sagen, entspannen Sie sich von mir, Sie können sich komplett ausziehen. Ich bin total im Reinen mit meiner Männlichkeit, ich wollte nur, dass jetzt nichts zu Missverständnissen kommt, dass Sie jetzt irgendwie so sagen, war es ein Achtzehner, ein Dreier? Ich verstehe Sie. Also ne, sowas nicht, sondern einfach. Ich bin ein Profi, ich bin ein Profi. Stellen Sie sich mich vor wie einen massiv übergewichtigen Vierjährigen, okay. Einfach zu gross für mein Alter, zu schwer für mein Alter, ich bin vier Jahre alt.
Okay.
Okay, sind wir an dem Punkt angekommen.
Genau.
Jetzt kommt meine Frage.
Mit Sägespern im Gesicht.
So.
Und zwar suche ich sowas wie einen scharfen Löffel.
Pff, was soll das denn sein?
Ach Gott, ich wusste es.
Oh, Leonie, Leonie, komm mal her, Leonie, komm mal her, du auch, Peter, alle vorbei. Bitte nicht, bitte nicht, der Typ, verstehen Sie, nein, ich brauche so ein Werkzeug. What is that, Ethan, ein scharfer Löffel, wow, wollen Sie eine spitze Gabel dann auch noch haben? Ich wünsche einen schönen Tag, Sieben, Joan, seht wie er läuft, wie er läuft, seht wie er übergewichtig ist, der vierjährige wegläuft. Okay, ich gehe, ja, das brauche ich jetzt nicht. Bitte, ciao, da ist die Tür, da ist die Tür. Aber ich konnte es wirklich nicht anders beschreiben, weil ich brauchte etwas, womit ich in den Styrodur rein kann und was rausschneiden. Also nicht eine Säge, sondern sowas wie ein Löffel. Möffel. Eigentlich ein Schöffel. Ein scharfer Löffel ist auch ein Schöffel. Ich brauche wie ein Messer. Pass auf, Göffel! Es gibt doch Göffel. Göffel ist Gabellöffel. Du brauchst Messerlöffel, Möffel. Aber stell dir vor, ich finde, das ist gar kein schlechtes Werkzeug. Zum Beispiel stell dir vor, du hast einen Leibkäse. Möffel. Es gibt es. Wie es gibt Möffel. Ich habe Möffel gegoogelt und es kommt ein scharfer Löffel. Und zwar mit diesen Haifischzähnen. Ja, nee, nee, ich will nicht die Haifischzähne. Stell dir einfach vor. Dann kann man sich an etwas reiben. Wenn du sagst Möffel und er sagt, hat die Haifischzähne, dann sagst du, nein, nicht die Haifischzähne. Dann kann man sich an etwas gemeinsam, kann man sich an etwas abarbeiten. Dann hast du schon was. Du hast in diesem luftleeren Vakuumraum zumindest schon etwas, wo man sich jetzt streiten kann. Stellen Sie sich vor, einen Löffel, aber die komplette, wie sagt man, die Schaufel ist einfach angeschärft. Die komplette Schaufel ist angeschärft. Stellen Sie sich vor, Sie wollen ein Leib Käse essen und Sie stellen ihn vor sich wie so eine Cornflakeschüssel und Sie gehen einfach mit ihrem Schöffel rein in den Käse und schneiden einfach Stücke Käse. Ich glaube, das ist kein schlechtes Besteck. Ich glaube, das ist kein schlechtes Besteck. Vielleicht müssen wir in der Zukunft Hybrid-Bestecken mehr Raum geben. Dass wir einfach sagen, pass auf, entweder wir erweitern die heilige Dreihigkeit des Bestecks, Messer, Löffel, Gabel mit dem Schöffel, oder wir sagen, pass auf, Messer raus, Löffel raus, Schöffel und wir haben nur noch Gabel und Schöffel. Möffel, also ich finde es, es tut mir leid, es gibt schon Göffel und Göffel sagt nicht, ich nehme das Runde eines Löffels und das Spitze eines Gabels, weil Göffel wäre auch schon ein Schöffel, weil es Spitzen hätte. Das kannst du nicht machen. Du musst das nehmen, woher sich die andere Eigenschaft leitet, was das Messer wäre, als ein Möffel. Tut mir leid. Ich bin unzufrieden mit dem Möffeldesign. Ich glaube, wir sind da falsch abgebogen. Wir hatten mal die Chance, das zu erweitern,
es gibt verschiedene Messer.
Es gibt ja die Sägezahnmesser
und es gibt die einfachen scharfen Messer, die genau das haben, was du suchst. Ja, ja, ja, genau. Nicht die Sägen. Nicht die Sägen. Aber ja, du hast, ich finde das auch. Stellt sich raus, sowas gibt es nicht und ich habe nichts bekommen. Ah, okay. Ich dachte nämlich immer, die wären einfach nur heiß. Heiße Löffel. Höffel. Weil, weil... Ja, das geht natürlich auch. Oder so Draht. Es gibt doch diese Drahtdinger. Aber ja, genau. Und die Drahtdinger ist das Problem, weil die Drahtdinger sind immer nur gerade. Mein Problem ist, ich habe ganz spezielle Ansprüche, die du, also die kriege ich jetzt in deinen Kopf da, also deinen kleinen Kopf, wo die Klappe eh schon halb zu ist. Hey, hey, ich bin einfach nur ein Obi-Mitarbeiter. Nein, sorry, bei dir ist einfach auf Kipp. Ich bin einfach nur ein Obi-Mitarbeiter. Ich weiß nicht, warum Sie jetzt anfangen sind. Nein, aber bei dir ist einfach das Fenster auf Kipp gerade. Sir, ich drücke gleich den Knopf hier unten. Ich drücke gleich den Alarmknopf. Was passiert dann? Da kriege ich Sägespäne ins Gesicht oder was? Vielleicht. Okay, das will ich nicht riskieren. Da wurde ich bei Obi schon gedemütigt. Obi, die behalte ich gleich an. Oder so. Obi, der Baumarkt, der atmet. Was? Was? We don't know. Wir haben gelitten in der Corona-Zeit, wir haben kein Geld mehr. Lass uns doch was mit dem ... Wir tragen andere auf, andere Slogans. Andere Seiten werden aufgezogen. Lass uns doch was mit dem Biber machen. Biber zu Obi, wie Lieber zu, verstehst du? Biber zu Bobi. Biber zu Bobi? Okay, das ist am Ziel vorbeigeschlossen, finde ich. Ich war noch nicht auch im Baumarkt und habe zum ersten Mal gewogen, weil ich habe zum ersten Mal in die Obstabteilung der Schrauben, der Baumärkte gegriffen. Wenn du reinkommst rechts. Ist klar. Da warst du jetzt links. Das verwirrt mich jetzt schon wieder, weil ich dachte, alle Baumärkte werden gleich aufgebaut. Ich habe jedenfalls da reingegriffen und sah nur neben jemandem so einer Kirmestüte stehen. Ja. Dann habe ich gesagt, was mache ich jetzt damit? Ich dachte, ich muss dann irgendwie jetzt die Zahl merken
und dann jede Schraube selber
dann quasi abkassieren lassen.
Nee, dann konnte man die wiegen.
Dann musste man quasi sich so eine Tüte ziehen,
zur Waage gehen und dann konnte man
die Nummer eingeben und dann konnte
man anhand, dann hat er gecheckt,
ah ja, das macht schon Sinn.
Diese Zahl M19
dieser Schrauben, die sind so und so schwer.
Das heißt, er hat, wenn ich das dann drauflege,
zehn Schrauben sich genommen.
Moment, der kann am Gesamtgewicht
zurückrechnen, was da drin ist?
Muss ja. Oder haben die Nettogewicht.
Ich habe mir eingeredet,
dass er das dividiert.
Ich glaube aber, du hast recht, ich glaube, der hat einfach
das Gewicht
mal eine Summe genommen. M19 kostet halt pro Gramm so und so viel. Meinst du? Und hast du ... Nein, ich habe mich nicht getragen. Naja, komm. Die kosten so wenig. Jeder macht so ein bisschen, dass man die Tüten noch so ein bisschen festhält. Komm, stell an. Nein. Ah, natürlich. Nein, ich dachte. Komm, natürlich, das macht jeder. Und dann habe ich zu Hause festgestellt, dass ich komplett völlig falsch gedacht habe. Ich wollte nämlich, ich war erst beim Zuschnitt, auch geil, Zuschnitt, toll. Wo man, man will nur Leute nicht aufhalten, weil die Schlange ist unglaublich lang beim Zuschnitt und man will nicht Leute aufhalten. Man geht da hin und sagt, bitte einmal auf 19 cm und dann hofft man, dass man sich nicht versprochen hat und der das macht und es kein Problem gibt und man gehen kann.
Ah, neunzehn Zentimeter, äh, neunzehn, aber egal, nee, ist egal, machen wie Sie meinen, wie Sie meinen, ciao, okay, ciao.
Dann wollte ich einfach nur ein Brett an die Wand machen und habe mir so Winkel gekauft und dann die richtigen Schrauben dafür. Und ich habe so lange Schrauben gekauft, was Sinn macht für die Wand. Dass sie bei einem Nachbarn rausgekommen sind. Aber es macht nicht Sinn bei dem Brett, weil das Brett ist nur ganz schmal. Aber ich habe mir so zehn Zentimeter Klopper gekauft, die natürlich, wie dumm,
keinen Sinn ergeben bei diesem kleinen Brettchen.
Ja. Jetzt weiss ich nicht,
wie ich das machen soll. Das bräuchte ich ganz, ganz, aber ich verstehe auch nicht,
weil die Schrauben, die ich bräuchte, sind ja super kurz. Das ist ja nie im Leben
stabil. Ja.
Du musst jetzt rausschauen, du kannst sie dann so absägen.
Aber das macht man auch nicht. Das macht man überhaupt nicht.
Aber das ist immer meine Lieblingsvorstellung, wenn ich irgendwas an die
Wand bohre, dass ich ihm immer mal vorstelle, mein Nachbar sitzt so in seinem Zimmer mit der Zeitung, Tasse Tee und plötzlich so kommt da so ein kleiner Schaumkopf so durch und er Ja, dann geht das so zurück und dann so dein Auge ah, Herr Riebling mein Auge, oh, Herr Riebling das tut mir jetzt leid, Herr Tietze ja, das tut mir jetzt sehr leid das habe ich, das habe ich durchge, bin ich durchgekommen ist doch kein Problem, ich hänge das Bild um haben Sie denn noch genug Bilder? Ich habe noch zwei Bilder.
Sie können noch zweimal durchbrechen.
Das ist mir jetzt unangenehm.
Die Wände sind aber auch dünn.
Sie sind wirklich dünn. Die sind wirklich dünn.
Manchmal kann man durchriechen, wenn man ganz nah an die Wand geht.
Ja, wenn man ganz nah an die Wand geht.
Ja, nicht mal dann.
Man kann auch so durchriechen.
Ja, das stimmt.
Deswegen wollte ich mal über das neue Parfum ihrer Frau reden.
Ja.
Gefällt mir nicht.
Chanel Nummer fünf. Das hatte meine Ex-Fre neue Parfum ihrer Frau reden. Ja. Gefällt mir nicht, Chanel Nummer fünf.
Das hatte meine Ex-Freundin.
Mir gefällt's auch nicht.
Sagen Sie, wenn Sie morgen Tatort hier schaut, dann hänge ich das Bild mal noch nicht um.
Und wenn Sie morgen hier Tatort schauen, dann können Sie ja durch das Loch mit ihr reden.
Nee, ich würde einfach so bei mir sitzen und sagen, oh, das verstinkt denn hier so. Das müssen Sie laut sagen, ja, ja, aber bitte, das ist gut. Okay. Wollen wir das jetzt alles reenacten? Wollen wir das alles reenacten? Wo steigen wir ein? Wollen wir den Abend noch erleben? Schatz, guck mal, die haben statt Tatort senden die jetzt Wetten, dass die mussten das Programm umstellen, steht hier im Teletext. Was stinkt denn hier so? Guck mal, aber Wetten, das würde ich aber auch gern schauen. Das können wir jetzt zusammenschauen. Was stinkt denn hier so nach Chanel Nummer 5? Hast du was gehört, Schatz? Nee, ich hab nichts gehört. Was stinkt denn hier so nach Chanel Nummer fünf, ii, das trägt man aber nicht mehr. Sag mal, hast du das gehört, was die Wand gesagt hat? Das riecht man aber nicht mehr, das trägt man nicht mehr, das ist unmodern. Ach, und jetzt schau ich lieber weiter Wetten, dass. Sie sind leider eine Sekunde hinter uns. Es war ja schon schon, dass die Wettel voll funktioniert hat. Dieser Sketch spielt in 2018. In Magdeburg, in der Freifnerstrasse 19a, im zweiten Stock. Nur für die Historiker. Ja, aber ich habe auch immer die Angst, wenn ich anfange zu bohren, habe ich auch immer schon meine genervten Nachbarn so im Kopf, was natürlich unsinnig ist. Wobei, wenn man selber reagiert, wenn man selber hört, ah, jemand bohrt gerade, ich ergehe das mal, ja, es ist ja gleich wieder vorbei. Es ist ja kein, es ist ja jetzt nicht, dass es die nächsten zwölf Stunden dieses Geräusch ertragen muss. Aber trotzdem habe ich immer so ein Sorry-Gesicht, so ein Sorry-Sorry. Und ich mache auch jedes Mal den gleichen Fehler, weil ich mir immer denke, kleben ist doch besser. Kleben ist doch besser. Ja, ich zeige mit meinen Händen gestikulierlich im Raum rum, wo ich versucht habe, Dinge aufzukleben, um die Wände nicht zu belasten. Weil ich habe hier immer so grosse, so akustische Absorber, habe ich hier an die Wand geklebt, weil ich dachte, wir sind hier gemietet, wir können uns hier nicht erlauben, in die Wände zu beschädigen und beide, beide grossen Kästen, die ich an die Wand klebte, fielen über Nacht im lauten Rums oder, was ich doch lustiger fände, tagsüber, während unsere Kollegen das hier hören, hier aber niemand im Raum ist, sie denken, ah, Poltergeister nebenan bei Tietz und Will GbR, was machen die denn da?
Es ist das schönste Gefühl, wenn du in einen Raum kommst, wo irgendwas von der Wand runtergekracht ist, du es aber nicht mitbekommen hast.
Und ich stelle mir immer nur vor, so diesen Schnitt zurück, fünf Sekunden bevor es passiert. Die Uhr. Boom! Und die Welt sollte nie wieder die gleiche sein. Ist ein bisschen wie das alte Sprichwort, ne? Fällt ein Baum tatsächlich um im Wald, wenn man nicht dabei ist? Ich glaube, ob er umfällt, ist nicht die Frage. Sorry, sorry. Ist er wirklich umgefallen? Halt mal jetzt deine Fresse. Macht der Wald ein Ge... Macht der Baum! Wenn... Hallo, seid ihr noch da? Wenn... Der antike Philosoph Stefan geriet in Vergessenheit, nachdem seine Gleichnisse nicht den gleichen... Hey, hey, Geschichtsbuch! Er geriet in Vergessenheit. Warum, warum? Er geriet in Vergessenheit. Weil ich mich versprochen habe. Weil seine Gedank Gedankenexperimente nicht so intelligent waren, die von anderen Philosophen. Wir haben in dem Buch drei Seiten für die Antike. Glaubst du, da passt du rein oder was? Mit deinem, wenn Baum umfällt, alleine ist da dein Umgefallen. Das hast du aber nicht gesagt. Das hast du aber nicht in Marmor grapieren lassen. Stopp, nein, nein, nein, nein, Buch. Nein, Plato, wir nehmen Platon rein. Platon heißt der Mann. So, ich werde, also. Ich weiß nicht, ob du es besser weißt. Alles klar, tschüss. So kommst du mir erst mal gar nicht. Raus, raus. Wenn ein Baum im Wald umfällt,
aber wir stehen nicht daneben,
macht er dann ein Geräusch?
Wenn du im Wald deine erbärmliche
Philosophie vorträgst und niemand
ist dabei, hast du es dann gesagt?
Können Sie sich wiederholen?
Können Sie sich die Frage wiederholen?
Finde ich aber eigentlich eine ganz geile
Sketchreihe, oder? So der Verlag von so Geschichtsbüchern und dann kommen immer so historische Personen rein. Die da rein wollen. Dann kommt Kleopatra und sagt, also was sie über mich geschrieben haben, ist ja völliger Schwachsinn. Sie haben mich ja dargestellt, als würde ich den ganzen Tag nur irgendwelche Schönheitsrituale machen. Ich habe drei Kriege gewonnen. Das Rentensystem erfunden. Ich habe die Rieser-Rente mit auf den Weg gebracht. Pyramiden nochmal 200 Meter gegründet und ich habe Hockey erfunden und sie machen von wegen Milchbart und irgendwie, als wäre ich so eine Beauty-Bloggerin oder was, was soll das? Ich meine, ja, ich kann mich auch toll schminken, aber das ist jetzt nicht Teil, ich will nicht dafür bekannt werden. Das ist gerade meine ganze Persönlichkeit. Und diese Scheiß-Romanze mit Cäsar, wen interessiert's? Das waren zwei Wochen. Ja, zwei intensive Wochen. Schöne Wochen. Das waren tolle Wochen. Cleopatra, was stehst du jetzt hinter dieser Schattenwand und läst das? Ist Cäsar im Call? Ja, hi, ich bin Cäsar, hi. Warum ist Cäsar auch im Call? Das ist wieder so typisch, dass ihr in eurer Scheiss-Verlags-Meeting wieder uns beiden den gleichen Call nehmt. Wir haben vierhundert Jahre voneinander entfernt gelebt. Wie meinst du das gerade, wie hast du das gerade gemeint mit dem, ähm... Och Gott, Julius, ich bitte dich, jetzt komm doch nie wieder mit dem alten Scheiss. Nämlich nicht Julius, ich möchte das nicht genannt werden. Cäsar möchteannt werden. Caesar. Nicht Julius. Und Gaius ist komplett raus, oder was? Auch okay. Gaius klingt auch mächtig, aber Julius. Jedes Mal, wenn ich mit dir rede, willst du anders genannt werden. Man leg dich mal fest. Nee, ich meine, für mich habe ich ja schon mal gesagt, die zwei Wochen waren für mich irgendwie mehr als es für dich. Ja, okay, sonst noch was? Hast du das nicht zu sagen? Ich meine, weil dir ist es doch auch gefallen. Du hast mir gesagt, du hast mir noch gesagt, wie toll es mit uns war und so. Das war die schönste Zeit irgendwie mit uns. Du, das war vor zweieinhalbtausend Jahren, das ist dir schon klar. Das ist jetzt wirklich lange her. Du, an einem gewissen Punkt musst du auch weitermachen. Du hast gesagt, du brauchst Zeit. Ich frage ihr nur, wie lange noch? Gib mir noch mal zweieinhalbtausend Jahre. Zweieinhalbtausend Jahre. Jesus. Du, wirklich, diese Rieser-Rente, das ist eine harte Nuss. Da sitze ich noch eine Weile dran. Währenddessen Karl Marx calling. Oh Gott, Leute, alle aus dem Call. Raus, raus. Alle aus dem Call. Der labert nur, der labert und schwafelt. Der will der ganze Tag hinweg wieder. Karl. Karl, ja, du. Karl, ich muss dich an der Stelle abwürgen. Du, sorry, ich weiß, du bist bei Kapitel zwei von zwölf, aber ich muss, sorry, ich muss dich kurz hier abwürgen. Aber kann man sich doch vorstellen, oder? Jede Folge kommt eine neue historische Figur und beschwert sich, was sie dargestellt wurde. Da brauchen wir jetzt gar nicht in den großen Rahmen drum machen. Wir können jede Woche im Podcast eine neue historische
Figur sich beschweren lassen. Okay, nächste Woche Jack the Ripper.
Okay. Ich hab nicht nur gerippt.
Nee.
Ich hab ganz tolle, ich hab
ein Album hinterlassen. Ich hab denen auch so
ein Ohrring ins Ohr gemacht.
Und außerdem kann mir das niemand nachweisen,
dass ich das war. Ja, das ist hier komplett
Schmierkampagne in euren Büchern die ganze
Zeit.
Ähm, aber das war nur ein kleiner Ausschnitt, denn das kommt nächste Woche. Das wird die nächste Woche. Nicht, denn wir haben es bis dahin wieder vergessen. Denn wir sind vergesslich, wir sind dusselig. Ist Geschichte nicht dafür da, dass man es auch mal vergessen kann? Schreibt man nicht Geschichtsbücher, damit man es dann vergessen kann? Aber wenn ein, und deswegen meine ich, wenn ein Baum umfällt, glaube ich nämlich, dass der, und jetzt nagelt mich gern drauf fest, ich bin der Meinung, der macht auch ein Geräusch, wenn man nicht daneben steht. Du willst dich jetzt wirklich festlegen. Das ist eines der Sprichwörter, was ich jetzt mal abschliessend klären möchte. Ja, es macht auch ein Geräusch, selbst wenn wir nicht da sind.
Hören wir das Geräusch?
Nein. Passiert es trotzdem? Ja.
Stelle ich noch eine dritte rhetorische Frage?
Ja.
Ich kann mit einer Hand klatschen.
Du auch? Ja, nein, aber sehr leise.
Nee, Mama?
Aber das ist kein Klatschen.
Du kannst besser klatschen.
Ganz kurz, ich klatsche es mal mit einer Hand und die Hörer müssen raten, ob links oder rechts.
Das war links.
Okay, Achtung, Runde zwei. Links oder rechts? Das war auch links. Aber das heißt, du könntest jetzt theoretisch einen Applaus nachmachen. Ja. Weil was wir normalen Sterblichen nicht können, ist, wir haben ja so zwei Hände zur Verfügung. Du hast nur einen Rhythmus, ja. Du kannst das polyrhythmisch klatschen. Okay, Achtung. Das ist aber schmerzhaft, ey. Das ist wirklich schmerzhaft. Gesicht verzogen. Ich muss mich entlegen. Brauchen wir neue Rubriken oder? So ein kleines interaktives Rätsel mal, warum nicht? Nee, warum nicht, finde ich auch nicht so schlecht. Wir haben nämlich ganz tolle Nachrichten bekommen im Reddit. Schaut da mal vorbei, das Podcast UFO, Reddit, da werden tolle Sachen gesammelt. Slash das Podcast UFO. Wir haben viele coole neue Kostüme und oder Symbolideen bekommen für unsere ... Die GO. Die GO. Die GO ist in der Schaffensphase blockiert. Die Gesellschaftsordnung. Die Gesellschaftsordnung, die gerade im Schlüpfen ist. Die wird gerade ausgebrütet quasi, so würde ich es beschreiben. Ich finde die Idee gut, dass sie so große pelzige Hüte haben, wie die britischen die royalen Wachen, finde ich nicht so schlecht. Einfach damit die auffallen im Straßenverkehr. Ja, auf jeden Fall. Damit, wenn du neben mir stehst mit deinem Taser, die haben auch nur einen Taser. Eigentlich, ich finde zwei Taser gut. Links und rechts in der Hand Taser. Oder halt so ein Nunchuk. Also dass man da auch so... Unter Strom gesetzt aber. Weil dieser Stromaspekt, den finde ich wichtig. So eine Elektropeitsche.
Ja.
Es ist so schwer, neue Dinge zu erfinden.
Ich war als Kind ja großer Star Wars-Fan
und wollte quasi auch Star Wars schreiben,
nur leicht anders, damit Copyright technisch keine Probleme gibt.
Ich fand, ich habe bessere Episoden geschrieben als Disney.
Du hast doch gesagt, Andor gefällt dir.
Ja, das war jetzt auf die anderen Filme bezogen. Das war jetzt zum Beispiel auf Star Wars 9 bezogen. Sorry. Naja, also, und da musste ich mir natürlich eine Alternative für das Lichtschwert überlegen. Und er dachte, die Lichtpeitsche. Ich dachte mir, wie cool diese Peitsche ist. Aber eine Peitsche ist nicht cool.
Während du Star Wars nachgeschrieben hast,
habe ich Hellringe nachgeschrieben, wo meine Helden statt Axt, Bogen und Schwert
hatten sie einen Ninja mit Nunchuks, eine Armbrust.
Und es gab exakt die Szene, du hast mein Schwert.
Und das halt mit viel wideren Dingen, dass es nicht einfach so eine Szene gewesen wäre, meine, du hast mein Schwert, du hast mein, und das halt mit viel
weirderen Dingen, dass es nicht einfach so eine Szene
gewesen wäre, hier und du hast mein Bogen,
sondern es war, du hast meine helle Bade,
alle wären so,
brauchen wir das, brauchen wir das, du hast mein
Pflege, weil es wäre nicht so eine Szene
gewesen, die hätte man nicht so stehen lassen können,
du hast, hier,
du hast meine Nunchucks,
okay, können wir aufhören, einfach random Dinge auf diesen Felsblock zu legen. Es ist mega weird. Ich habe drei Waffen, welche sage ich, du hast meinen Bauernspieß. So, okay. Wir haben auch genug Leute, wir haben genug Leute. Ich verstehe nicht, warum Leute anfangen jetzt hier random irgendwie ihre Wasserflaschen noch hier hin zu. Du hast meine, nein, es reicht, wir haben genug. Das ist so, wie wenn Herr der Ringe von Nerds von mittelalterlichen Waffen geschrieben worden wäre, mit so hier meinen Färschen, so ganz spezifischen Namen einfach so, es interessiert niemanden, Pickel. Ja. Und dann noch ein Nachtrag zu den Namen, die zu berufen passen. Ich weiß, wir haben das schon selber wütend gesagt, hört auf uns das zu schicken, es reicht, es reicht, es reicht. Aber Molesti war schon witzig. Aber Patrick Molesti hat seinen Namen zu ernst genommen. Ich kann darüber nur lachen. Es tut mir so leid, aber Patrick Molesti, there were red flags. Ja, meinst du, auch so im Kindergartenvorstand gibt es einen, der gesagt hat, Molesti, lass uns den nicht einstellen, so mit verschränkten Armen. Habe ich es euch gesagt?
Ach Charlotte, wir können doch nicht nur anhand der Namen die Leute nicht einstellen. Charlotte Rechthab. Ja. Charlotte Rechthab. Ich bin auch nur wegen meinem Namen hier. Er ist nicht umsonst Vorsitzender dieses Kindergartens. Patrick Molesti hätte nicht. Aber die Frage an uns als Gesellschaft jetzt. sollten wir jetzt Patrick Molestis oder Jakob Molestis nicht mehr einstellen als Kindergärten? Oder Samantha Molesti. Oder Samantha Molestis. Sollte man die jetzt nicht mehr einstellen als Kindergärten? Ich meine, gut, es gibt sehr viele andere Jobs, die sie ausüben könnten, vielleicht, aber vielleicht ist es auch einfach deren Traum. Wer sind wir jetzt, Sabrina Molesti zu verwehren, bei uns
Kindergärterin zu sein? Ich hätte gerne bei
diesem Herrn Molesti gern so ein Flashback
zu allen anderen
Nachnamen, die die Familie
nicht genommen hat,
sondern bei Molesti geblieben ist.
Welche Namen wurden in dieser jahrhundertelangen
Dynastie alle verworfen, dass man
gesagt hat, nee, lass uns dann doch
bei Medici, alle
Hohenzollern,
Goebbels, okay, gut, da kann man es verstehen.
Gut, ja, ja, nee, nee, nee, nee,
den gebe ich dir, man hat einen Fränchen.
Molesti.
Ach, sehr schön. Ja, genau, den fanden wir jetzt
noch gut.
Ich glaube, damit ist der
Sack zu. Es sei denn, ist es noch mal so gut, aber das ist schwer zu top. Und bitte nicht grüssen im Reddit. Grüss nicht im Reddit. Grüsser sind die Feinde der Hörer. Völlig richtig. Sorry, ich bin noch ein bisschen krank. Nächste Woche wird alles wieder more high energy. Okay. Okay? Alles klar.
Ich freue mich drauf.
Ich möchte bei dir entschuldigen.
Überhaupt nichts zu entschuldigen.
Man kann auch noch mal eine ruhige Folge machen.
Introspektiv, wir haben alle was gelernt.
Und jetzt heben wir ab.
Okay?
Okay.
Auch mal locker abheben.
Macht's gut, Leute.
Bis nächste Woche.
Nee, start noch mal richtig.
Start noch mal richtig.
Sorry, Entschuldigung.
Du musst den Schlüssel richtig einmal ganz doll umdrehen.
Ja, weil einfach, ja, sorry, weil ich hab ein bisschen Angst.
Wenn du die Bremse nicht drückst, hab ich schon ein paar Mal gesagt, dann schritte das Ding nicht an.
Ja, ja, okay, okay.
Die Möhre nicht an.
Okay, und los.
It's the worst by our production. Der Euro-Jackpot ist immer noch ungeknackt, jetzt 120 Millionen Euro in Klasse 1 und rund 21 Millionen in Klasse 2 zu gewinnen.
Das Leben könnte so Jackpot sein, in jeder Lotto-Annahmestelle und auf lottobayern.de.
Lotto Bayern, nimm dein Glück in die Hand.
Spielteilnahme ab 18, Chance auf den Höchstgewinn 1 zu 140 Millionen, Glücksspiel kann süchtig machen, Hilfe unter b Glück in die Hand.